- [Kelly] You look so cute.
(crowd cheering)
- Oh, thank you.
- With your freckles.
Everything.
- Thank you.
- Have y'all ever met?
Say hi to Jeff
- No.
if y'all haven't met.
- We have not.
- How are you?
- She's stunning.
- Thank you.
- You are stunning.
- I know you walked down here
And I was like, wait what?
- Oh, thanks so much.
- You look so beautiful.
Well like me, we are both from the south.
You're from the south, right?
- I was born in Kentucky.
- You're born in Kentucky.
- Yeah. I moved there very,
I moved out of Kentucky
when I was like three months old.
- Where, where did you,
so you remember a lot?
- I remember a lot.
- It really was, it made an impact.
So wait, where did you
start dancing though?
- Here in LA, so--
- So you moved from there to LA?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- So I started training
and dance really young.
I think I was four years old
and I started taking ballet.
Tap, jazz, hip hop. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Look how cute you are.
- Yeah. So it's been a lifetime
passion of mine.
- I love that.
It feels good.
- [Tinashe] Yeah.
- I love dancing.
- It feels so good.
- Yeah.
I think it's very underrated.
How much of like a cathartic--
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- release it is.
- [Kelly] Therapeutic dance.
- Totally is.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- What's your finest dancing moment, sir?
I'm guessing a wedding reception.
- That's why I tell jokes.
When I dance, people pledge
money to find a cure.
It's not good.
Not good.
- Oh my God.
- We could do a duet or something.
- Those are the dancers
I actually love watching.
So wait, so I heard that the first album
you bought was Britney Spears.
Is that true?
- [Tinashe] Yes.
- Which one?
- "Baby One More Time"
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay.
- was the very first CD of mine
that I owned
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- that was very much mine.
And I ended up working
with her, which is crazy.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- Crazy.
- [Kelly] What did y'all work on together?
- [Tinashe] So I was a feature on
one of her songs on her album.
It was called "Slumber Party".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- [Tinashe] I'm telling you, it was--
- [Kelly] Look at your smile.
- Because I was like in heaven.
It still feels really surreal
just to be able to work
with somebody that, you
know, you've idolized--
- Since you were a kid.
- your entire life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was, was really, really really crazy.
Still to this day, I'm like,
I can't believe that happened.
- She's super sweet too.
- She's so sweet.
- So kind. Yeah.
- It was so nice to meet her in real life.
- I know. It's always nice when
you see someone that's blown up so big
but they're still very humble and sweet--
- Yeah.
- in person.
- Totally authentic.
Like she's Britney, 100 percent.
And to see her star
power on stage as well.
Like when you're actually
on the stage with her,
like filming a music video
with her, the camera's rolling.
- [Kelly] Do you feel it?
- You just see that
character come out of her
and you're like, oh wow.
That's Britney Spears.
- But like, you're that
person now too, though.
So that feels good, right?
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- So you have a deluxe edition
of your album "333" and it's out now.
So tell us about it.
Why is it called "333"?
Is that like a favorite number?
- Yeah.
Well, it's an angel number
- [Kelly] Oh.
- and angel numbers to me represent,
you know, that you're
guided, you're protected.
Everything is going the way it should be.
- [Kelly] And what's an angel number?
- Well, angel numbers are these, I guess,
sequences of numbers
that kind of represents different things.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So when you see them in
your day to day life,
or you experience, for me,
333 has always been like
a significant one.
When I see it, I'm like,
okay, I'm on the right path.
Everything's gonna be okay.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- I'm moving in the right direction.
And so I think it's good to
have those reminders around you
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- from time to time whatever
your positive omen is for you.
And I wanted to be able to
share that with my fans.
- That's really important
'cause that's how fans connect to you.
- Absolutely. I think that's how you
be authentic as an artist.
Also, I just like doing
things that are unexpected.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So Valentine's Day was coming up
and I was like, you know what
would be really unexpected?
If I made a horror movie where I was
like Dexter slicing
something up, you know?
I, I don't know.
It just felt very opposite.
- [Kelly] You should do acting too.
I was watching your videos too.
You're very good.
- Thank you.
I acted when I was a
little girl and growing up.
I did my last thing when I was like 15.
Kind of stepped into
music, but I was like,
if I come back,
- [Kelly] you can do both.
- A horror movie.
- Yes.
- [Tinashe] This is my audition.
- You scared the hell
outta me in the video.
So, yeah, no I just thought I was like,
man, you're really good.
- [Tinashe] Thanks.
- You should probably act too.
Yeah. Just saying, just think about it.
So wait, so you're performing
"Naturally" today, right?
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
- Every time I say your
name, the crowd goes wild.
They're very excited about this.
- I got some fans in audience.
Thank you guys so much for coming.
- Aww. So what's the theme of the song?
- So this song is, it's kind of like
a cute love song in one regard.
But then I think if you
really listen to the lyrics
and you get a little bit deeper with it,
you see there's a lot of layers to it.
Like there's some obsession there,
there's some lusting there,
there's some, you know,
depending on how you interpret it,
I think the song can either be
like a cute, happy love song
or it can be like, oh,
this is interesting.
There's some layers, you know?
- Yeah. I love that about music though.
Everybody listens to it
and kind of gets their own story from it.
Yeah, absolutely.
- I love that.